jd just started recently asking for
substitutions at restaurants and he told
me the reason he didn't ask for
substitutions is because he had too much
anxiety what would you have that you
would have wanted to substitute okay
i'll tell you the story so i was at a
restaurant we're at a restaurant
and i wanted to order the duck all right
but i didn't like the side the side was
like you know broccoli rob or something
like that so
i looked at the other items and the only
other thing that had a decent side i
thought was the filet mignon
uh which had a potato side so but i
didn't want the filet mignon i wanted to
duck and so
i was
stared at this menu
over and over everyone else is like
conversating like having a conversation
and all i could think about is am i
gonna get the duck or the filet mignon
you know based on the size and then
finally uh you know i i i said something
to someone and they actually spoke up
for me when the waiter came over and
said hey you know you know what do you
want i go well i'll get the duck and uh
and then the person said well can you
replace the sides for him and uh the
waiter said yes and uh yeah meanwhile
how old were you when that happened
like last year so right
yeah exactly
well i get worried about like you know
people spitting in my food or whatever
like you know
so you know
some of these restaurants the the chefs
they
i i feel they could take offense if you
don't get the the whole you know so
that's my own thing yeah by the way on
our phone is the chef
that was there the night that jd
substituted
great broccoli rob for potatoes
what was that night like for you chef
bonjour it was horrible for me because i
said simple this simple food the side is
meant to complement the meal so you you
know what i do it's my favorite thing to
do in the world
i piss in these nurse potatoes i love
nothing more than to pee in a nerd food
and then i laugh when i watch
i love you so much jd do you think you
could ask for a substitution now well
actually the sort of uh the thing
happened this past weekend we were at an
italian restaurant and
uh it was either chicken parm
or uh what was it some other the the
pasta uh [ __ ]
some other type of pasta
and she said that she could substitute
the
the i guess it's it's not it's spaghetti
that comes with chicken farm she could
substitute the
uh that pasta with the instead of the
spaghetti so she did that
i thought you know jd you had a
conversation about that yeah
i got to tell you i got to tell you i
want to give you a hug right now i wish
i could just i could just wrap you up in
my arms and give you a hug
the way you just told that story
i have no [ __ ] clue what you're
talking about try to simply say what
happened if you don't well i got caught
on the other type of pasta because i
couldn't remember what it was um i had
it was i wanted the chicken parm but i
didn't really want the spaghetti so i
almost got this other type of pasta
instead but the waitress said she could
substitute that spaghetti with the other
type of pasta with the chicken parm i
was like oh thank you that's that's what
was the other type of pie i can't
remember what it was it was it's like uh
it's the pasta with stuff inside usually
um
i can't think of it uh stuffed shells
no it's not like it's not ravioli but
it's
something like that
i gotta give you a bigger tortellini i
got a i got a tortellini i can't
remember it's one of those was it
rigatoni maybe you had
maybe i got let me look it up hold on
let me look it up i want to know i want
and then i'm going to teach you how to
tell that story no that's not it let me
see
quickly
it wasn't the tortellini oh no it was
the tortellini it was totally done okay
that was so you go like this i went to
the restaurant yes
i don't enjoy spaghetti i wanted the
tortellini as a side
so i said to the woman with my chicken
parm can i get tortellini instead of
spaghetti and she said yes that's it
story over everyone gets i don't know if
that's what happened though well listen
i don't want to be a downer but maybe
you should skip the pasta all together
well you know what i'm saying play
mignon